[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm Ramsey personality
George camel joined by my good friend
and one of America's favorite John's Dr
John delone and we are here for you
America take making your calls at
8825 5225 maybe you need some advice
some motivation maybe you need to take
that next step with that broken
relationship the toxic boss the debt
that's been hanging over your head for
far too long and you're just ready to
make some changes and live a better more
peaceful life that's what we're all
about on this show Mary is going to kick
us off in Cleveland Ohio Mary welcome to
the
show Hi how are you doing today doing
well how are you
you um I'm going to be honest I'm a
little nervous and anxious right now we
got you Mary it's just us here just us
girls let's
talk okay what's going on um so I'm
calling in because my husband is a
gambling addict and has been since
January of this year when it became
legal in
Ohio um and is as the heaviest toll on
our marriage um on our relationship our
family and I'm at the point where I have
tried many routes with this trying to be
very gracious on how I go about it
trying to be respectful as a wife trying
to support his mistakes but trying to
get him the help he needs and nothing is
working um and at this point he is very
adamant about continuing to do it um and
I'm at the point where I feel that I
need to you know take my daughter and
take a step away not divorce but maybe
take some separation until he f figures
it out but I honestly don't want to have
to do that but I don't know what else to
do right now what makes you think that
or what's happening that you feel like I
need to get me and my daughter out of
this to be
safe well um I think you're right I
think you're right by the way but I want
you just articulate what something else
is going on like what's happening in
your
home it's just an extremely tense
environment we argue all the time um
which know we
we are you arguing because he's losing
thousands and thousands of dollars or
arguing because he's just glued to his
phone all the time and he's angry
because he wins and loses or as Mo as is
most of the time the gambling behavior
and The Addictive actions that are keep
like this
compulsion um is indicative of a much
bigger issue in your marriage y'all
don't talk to each other you don't
listen to each other there's no intimacy
it's just become a mess and gambling is
the way he's choosing to handle that
that Global dysfunction inside your home
correct okay all of it um yes and I mean
the lying is the biggest thing as well
so anytime somebody has a boundary
inside of a marriage that they're
thinking about laying down right like
this is this is my um this is my final
straw this is my line that I won't cross
anymore I always want to encourage them
to have an or what statement because the
person they laid the boundary down um is
going to want to know can you give an
example yes so you need to have an or
what statement you sit down with your
husband and say if we don't go to
marriage counseling by the end of this
weekend or we don't have a date on the
calendar by the end of this weekend and
it's next
week and if you don't
go here's the or what me and our
daughter are moving
out okay period you just have to be
prepared for the or what because the or
what comes with a lot of complexity and
I know it sounds super cool to be like
you like you're going you can Google
this and on these stupid websites
they're going to tell you like just
leave him you don't deserve that sounds
all well and good but there is a
significant financial complexity to this
right yeah and I I mean I really don't
want it to have to come still love him
of family together of course you
do I want you to keep this front and
center as you move forward you are
simply doing what you have to do to keep
your family safe and responding to
somebody that's thrown a grenade inside
your
home yeah you're not the one doing this
and he will paint you as the villain
here he has that's right because he gets
to do whatever he wants to do whenever
he wants to do it with quote unquote
y'all's money and he can you're just
whining and nagging and complaining and
on
and online gambling online Sports
gambling is
destroying individuals and homes across
this country period and dude I always
watch the fights I love watching the
games I love having fun with my friends
so it's not that I'm like this fdy ddy
that sits in my house and and plays
Bingo all the time I love I love the
whole environment and yet this is
destroying
people yeah and you've told them that
and he has told you I don't really care
what you have to say I'm going to keep
doing whatever I want to do
yeah and I mean it's it's been the past
few months um I guess to give just some
quick context uh so pretty much in a
lump sum he has spent between 30 to
$40,000 has he lost
it oh yeah like he's lost all all of it
okay we don't there there's no um I mean
he's you know won a couple thousand here
or 100 here things like that um but it's
it's he's all together um since the
beginning of this year it's been around
$40,000 um and can we be honest this is
what you know about I promise there's
more this is all I know
about let me ask you some a very
tactical question if you move out do you
have do you have a job do you have
money um yes I I I have a job but we um
so he's in nursing school so hold on
hold on hold on he is making choices you
are keeping yourself
safe if he's in nursing school then he
gets to take care of his pay for nursing
he gets to make those choices on his
own you need to have your four walls
covered for you and your baby if you
choose to you have your own bank
account yes I actually did um probably
about two months ago at this point um
that was one of the steps I took was
separating good our finances we never
recommend that except in this moment
does it direct does your check direct
deposit into that account it's still in
our joint um and I will just say so
pretty much because we don't have any
like we don't have any Financial
security right now so with my job and
his job we get paid each week so I get
paid and then he gets paid the following
and so on so forth so with our money
that we have right now I want to take
the money from like my check and put it
into ours but then all the bills come
out from our joint because we haven't
switched any of those yet so all of like
pretty much each paycheck that we get
each week is going towards bills going
towards groceries and gas and then
there's nothing left over I want you to
get with a friend and I want you to map
this out okay okay and you're going to
have to move your direct deposit to your
new
account and you know as well as I do
he's gonna hit the roof isn't
he yeah he he already did when I I mean
everything I do he he does that's right
are you
safe yes okay he's not going to hit you
or hurt you no okay so we are getting
with a friend and we're going to map
this out what's an apartment going to
cost what are the light and water bill
going to cost and we're going to get all
all this La mapped out and lined out
we're going to make sure that our check
can cover that and you might need to get
some new hours and all that kind of
stuff child care all those things and
then we're going we're going to sit down
and be very articulate and clear about
my or what statement this
changes or here's what I'm going to do
you can't control anything he does you
can only control what you do I hate that
you're in this situation stay on the
line we're going to hook you up with
every dollar so you can begin to control
what you can control if and when you
have to step away we'll be right
[Music]
back if you're like most people your
home is your most valuable asset and
when you want to make improvements it
can feel like everything costs too much
or takes too long but something as
simple as custom window coverings from
blinds.com can completely change your
space and add value to your home we've
recommended blinds.com for over a decade
so you know you can trust them from
blinds drapes and shutters to motorized
Shades they make it easy and affordable
to upgrade your entire home and their
team is ready to help with everything
from design consultation to measuring
and installation plus there are never
any misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by the their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free Cy blinds.com is the number
one online retailer of custom window
coverings visit blinds.com to get up to
45% off that's blinds.com rules and
restrictions May
[Music]
apply
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
give us a call at8
825-5222 Shelley joins us up next in
Dallas Texas Shelly welcome to the
show hi thank you for taking my calls um
I'm really just calling because I'm I've
been listening to the show a lot and I
know the baby steps and everything and I
know that I'm in a position where I can
afford therapy but my question is it's
just well it's not more of a question
it's just an emotional issue around
spending the money on therapy I just
feel bad I know I need it and my husband
supports me but you know just it just
makes me feel bad to
spend it cost a lot and my insurance
doesn't cover the the um license therapy
part of it um so what's it going to cost
for you to get this
help well I was looking at like better
help and you know there's U I even saw
some more affordable options too but um
so I did sign up with better help but
I'm just feeling like I'll try it for
you know the first four weeks and then
cancel it I I start something you know
I'll start it and and I started therapy
before but it was just costing like a
hundred a week and then I was do you
feel like this is a wasteful expense in
your budget right now like hey this
money should be going toward this what's
behind that I start feeling like I I
don't know it's and it's part of my
anxiety it's part of the reason why I
think I need therapy well I I think it
has nothing to do with money
I think money is the excuse that
presents itself that gives you an out so
that you don't have to go
through this fire where healing on the
other side of
it yeah it could be I don't know I think
you should go it's all confusing I I
honestly I don't I the feelings might be
confusing but even if you guys were up
to your eyeballs in debt and you need to
go to counseling we would tell you to
stop paying off your debt pause and go
to counseling get the help you and care
that you
need yeah I it's I'm trying to wrap I'm
trying to it's it's you can tell
yourself I know this is so important my
health but it just feels it just hurts
to pay I don't know I was raised poor
you know grew up in a poor family and
we're doing really well now and I just
feel like that's it right there we need
to right for the future you know why cuz
when you grew up other people those
people over there they they got
counseling they took quote unquote took
care of themselves we don't got time for
that we don't need that only weaklings
and wimps do
that yeah
right are those people it was you didn't
even want to say oh I need therapist
because you would in my family it would
be like oh well you're crazy you know
you know what in your family tell me if
I'm wrong in your family you didn't say
that you needed
anything no I I actually struggled with
eating disorder and everything starting
when I was a teenager now I'm in my 40s
and having panic attacks and I had a
traumatic event last year medical with
neuropathy for chronic pain for like
eight months in my face it's time and
it's time I can't sleep without heavy
medicine it's
time it's time whatever it takes if
there was a medication Shelly that was
$300 a month but it changed your life
would you say that was a worthy $300 to
spend that wasn't wasteful yeah and well
I am spending a lot on my psychiatrist
for the medicine so that's that I have
to have that or I just can't function
but your psychiatrist has been telling
you for a long time I'm going to give
you these meds but you need to go talk
to somebody haven't they yeah he did say
CDT would help me correct it's
time I think we need to refile this in
our brain as this is not a wasteful
thing that I could be spending in this
and this is it's too much in our budget
into hey this is like paying for
insurance this is keeping the lights on
this is paying for the internet bill
this is going to add so much utility and
value to my life that I can't imagine
not doing it and it may not be forever
this may be a season that you go through
and then it's
over yeah yeah I was kind of wondering
about I know everyone's different but I
was wondering about like on average kind
of how how long it could take you know
I've had friends tell me oh it took so
and so a year to to to Really but if you
strugg listen if you struggle with
tunnel if if you've struggled with
disordered eating since you were a child
and you grow up in a pretty tough place
in a pretty tough uh
situation and if you um think so little
of
yourself that the idea of spending money
to make sure you're whole and well so
that you can show up for you and for
your husband and for others if that
shuts your body down or shs off your
body's alarms it's going to be a
while so I think it's counterproductive
or I'm telling you it's
counterproductive to say okay I'll give
you four and I
quit that's like going to the to the car
dealer and saying or to the mechanic and
saying hey uh everything's broken on the
car you got 30 minutes and then I'm just
going to come pick it
up yeah I want you to completely reframe
dress on myself that I put the stress on
myself that I feel like I have to hurry
up and fix myself in this amount of time
well right and you're not somebody
listen I I used a bad analogy you're not
somebody to be fixed okay you're not
broken your body's working exactly as it
should given the set of circumstances
you grew up in plus some genetics and
what you're going to learn is different
ways your body can get through a day
that's that's what counseling is going
to do it's going to let you practice
it's going to teach you relationship
it's going to teach you some new skills
over time your body's going to learn hey
we weren't safe
then we're safe now all of that is
worthy of an investment go don't think
twice about it and and listen to this
this is important your feelings are not
designed to tell you the truth your
feelings are designed to keep you safe
given a set of
circumstances so this morning I did not
feel like writing in a journal I
didn't but I did it because I am a
better husband and a better dad on the
other side of that when I get all this
crap out of my head and out of my body
and on the piece of paper I will not
feel like working out when I get home
tonight I won't feel like it at all I'm
tired it's the weekend and I'm going to
go do it cuz I promised myself I would
and it makes me a better fill-in the
blank a fill in- the blank so your
feelings I feel like I want to quit cool
I get that I'm going to acknowledge
those feelings that's real and then I'm
going to keep going and I feel like I'm
wasting money cool I your body's your
body grew up poor put a GPS pin in
poverty and put a GPS pin and stop
spending money on quote unquote you
getting well cool I feel that and I'm
going to go anyway because I'm going to
get well I'm worth being well that's a
good word John and tactically Shelly
adding this as a lineup item in your
every dollar budget that says Shell's
therapy and then you know what's going
to happen is December it's going to feel
like oh gosh that $300 came out for
those sessions then January it's like oh
yeah we have that in the budget then
February it's like oh yeah we've had
this in the budget and all of a sudden
it becomes normal especially as you
Excel through the baby steps and you get
to a different place financially there's
expenses in my wife and I's budget that
you know 23-year-old George would be
like whoa that guy's blowing some money
and to us it's no we're buying ourselves
peace we're buying our time back with
some of these things and it's therapy is
not a luxury it is financially for
people who can't afford it but it's not
a frivolous expense and it's definitely
worth being well and John talks about
this in his new book building a
non-anxious life which I'd love to send
Shelly a copy of that John if you don't
mind absolutely and stay on the line I'm
going to hook you up with three free
months of better help with my friends
there okay I'm going to take that excuse
away three free months of better
help but if you and your therapist
decide hey it's probably best if you
keep going I want you to keep going and
stay plugged in that's very kind of you
John you wield that kind of power here
on the Ramsey Show I don't I've got an
extraordinary partner with better help
and they really really care about people
getting well and so um it's their
generosity not mine that's very kind so
hang on the line Shelley we're going to
send you a copy of Dr John delon's
bestselling book building a non-anxious
life and three months of better help on
us to get you started on this path we
are cheering you on and I'm proud of you
that's a that's not an easy thing to
call into a national radio show and put
that all out there and go I'm struggling
with this I want to get the help I need
and I know a lot of people are
benefiting from this call who probably
need to take that next step too John
dude I I remember being a 6'2 195 lb
Texas male sitting at my kitchen table
while my little boy was asleep and my
wife was asleep in the other room
Weeping at my kitchen table cuz I knew I
had to and I also felt like such a wimp
and such a weakling and such a coward
and all those things and I went and it's
changed everything go get the helping
care that you need thanks so much for
the call Shelly more of your calls
coming up the number is
88255 225 we'll be right
[Music]
back
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial piece and you don't see any
way out you need why refi they're not a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with why
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumps
some payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey welcome back to the Ramsey Show
I'm George joined by Dr John deloney
we've got a lot going on right now at
the Ramy solutions store on our website
at Ramy solutions.com store including
our $12 sale you can get a lot of
meaningful gifts for Christmas right now
bestselling books like The Total Money
Makeover baby steps millionaires own
your past change your future just 12
bucks each and questions for humans
conversations cards from my friend Dr
John delone as low as 10 bucks right now
and the Christmas edition is back that
one sells out quick you'll also notice a
whole bunch of new stuff our friend Jade
warshaw launch launched a new quick read
this week called money's not a math
problem Rachel Cruz has a great new kids
book out beautifully Illustrated called
them glad for what I have we've got the
2024 ramsy gold planner and of course my
new book Breaking Free from broke is now
on pre-sale and uh the support has been
overwhelming so thank you to all of you
who have pre-ordered that book and have
uh made your shopping list a little
easier with the Ramsey solutions.com
store getting meaningful gifts John
that's what it's all about you know I
don't know what you buy for Christmas
are you getting your kids anything
exciting dude I'm I have a problem yeah
do you want to talk about this off air
it feels I mean I just I just I I just
love buying gifts and so uh that's very
kind of you there was there was many
years when I couldn't and so now you're
you're making up for lost time yeah but
it's it's sometimes about me and not
about them and so it's very self-aware I
told I I I said on the show the other
day I told my son like we we were out
having a meal together and I said hey
this year like we're not just getting
you a bunch of junk and I'm going to get
you a couple of of of really important
things and a this and a this and he just
smiled at me and goes you can't do that
Dad and he like watch me well he was
right he's like Dad we don't need the
stuff but you can't do it so cool and it
was a good it was good so I called his
bluff he didn't get crap this year just
kidding he'll get a bunch of take that
yeah that's very kind of you I just like
buying gifts that's very I can't wait to
see what you get me this Christmas John
yeah maybe three months of better help
is in the cards for me that would be
nice no I got you a razor a scooter no
like oh for my face for your face I
should not have been that excited about
a Razor scooter I'm going to be honest
oh my goodness all right let's get to
the lines Ryan awaits in Syracuse New
York Ryan welcome to the
show hey guys can you hear me yes how
can we help today all right thanks for
having me on very blessed to be here
congrats on the new book as well oh
thank you I appreciate that
um I just wanted to get your guys' take
uh my wife and I just um were starting
to get more of a budget together um we
download the every dollar app we've been
trying to get more responsible um you
know with budgeting and everything um we
do have some debt that we want to try
clearing up over the course of the next
few years hopefully um you know we have
two kids and you know balancing that you
know life and and debt and everything um
I just wanted to get you guys take on it
on as possible okay well give us a
little more specificity here what's your
income and how much debt do you have so
yeah so um we more specifically the the
big things are we have a HELOC um
unfortunately that we did take out um
that's about 11,800 for renovations in
the home um and we have um I
specifically have about
$170,000 in in student loans and my wife
has about
50,000 um um bro are you a
surgeon no so I am um I'm a hospital
pharmacist okay um I I actually just um
I did get just passport certification
for to be specialized in infectious
disease so I'm hoping that takes me a
little farther in my career um and my
wife is um she's an elementary teacher
and she has her Masters in in education
um so the 50,000 is for graduate uh
Masters and then you know I I did do
quite a few years of of schooling um so
I guess my question is is we've been
trying to get better with budgeting our
take-home monthly for between her and I
is about
10,500 um uh so it's about 125,000 a
year takehome we ran the numbers we're
wondering where the heck is all this
money going um because we do have a
little bit left over um at the end of
each month so um I think right around
about 2
22300 um
theb that's with um that's yeah so
that's with minimum payments on the debt
um that's taken into account trying to
pay the keyock off a little bit earlier
um and putting a little bit extra money
towards that and then um budgeting for
you know anything you know for the kids
and for us and and all that just with
life and everything
okay well your plan right now sounds
like a 10-year plan to get rid of this
debt right yeah that kind of sucks I
want to live life more freely in the
meantime so what if you could sacrifice
for like three years and be totally done
with this debt yeah and so then you
start doing math and you go all right
that looks weirdly like you got $231,000
in debt over three years that's 77,000 a
year you tracking yep and now that means
every single month we need to be
throwing $6,400 at this debt that gives
us a real goal right now you're like
we're trying to pay off some debt or I
think it's going to be a little while
let's get really tactical and go we need
$6,400 going toward debt how do we make
that happen and for you guys that
probably looks like getting income up
ASAP that might mean taking some jobs
you normally wouldn't take because
you're a fancy Hospital pharmacist but
right now the extra thousand bucks a
month could change our life okay and it
might mean we got to cut expenses down
and Christmas looks different this year
and we're going to pick one person to
get the gift for instead of getting
something for everyone even though we're
fancy teachers and pharmacists you know
what I mean there's going to be
sacrifices here on both sides of
spending less and making more because I
want to see you out a debt in three
years and I think it's possible but
we're going to have to make some
lifestyle changes I want you to shoot
for two and a half
years yeah okay and listen you're I've
been where you are with my little fancy
graduate degree pulling into the parking
lot with my other colleagues and their
BMWs and in their Lexus and their nice
cars
yep you can either choose to be free or
not
man and that means people going to look
at you in the parking lot and be like
bro I know what you make what are you
doing aren't you the pharmacist yep and
I'm driving an old
Corolla I sold my other car because my
identity is not in that my identity is
in
Freedom yeah and I'm GNA work Saturdays
and Sundays because you can pick up
extra shifts you can go over to
Walgreens and pick up a shift there too
you can work as much as you want work
it's like yeah but I want to don't miss
this I don't want to miss that man
please get this stuff out of your life
as soon as possible yeah
okay so you're looking at yeah go ahead
sorry I want to help you out as well
with the budgeting side because you it
sounds like you guys are starting to
actually go where is this money going
and that's a great step to take I'm
going to take it one step further and
give you every dollar premium for a year
to really get down to the nuts and bolts
connect to your bank account use the
paycheck planning tool the financial
road map tool get both you and your wife
downloading this app looking at it every
day tracking that two or three
transactions making a plan going right
are we on track to put that 6,000
towards debt this month what do we got
to do to get there all right we got to
we're not going out to eat for a while
we're going to scrimp On The Go
groceries we're not taking that vacation
it's going to be 3 years 2 and a half
years of intensity but you're going to
have 30 years on the back side of
Freedom right okay you don't sound like
you like that answer well I no I I mean
I I I do um you know it it does sound
good um we you know my wife and I are
are we are focused too on on making sure
that the that our two girls are you know
taken care of and we you know we we're I
guess it was more of we wanted to try to
find a balance
between paying off the debt you know my
there won't be I guess my goal was yeah
I know it's got to be either one or the
other let me tell you this and I'm
saying this unequivocally and this is
neuroscience and and this is physiology
and you know this you and I have read
the same Journal
articles yeah the greatest gift you can
give your kids is not lessons in a thing
the greatest gift you can give your kids
is not a great present or a cool trip
is a non-anxious regulated adult in
their home two of them yeah and so the
greatest gift you can give your kids is
not attendance to every single solitary
soccer game and for 24 and a half or 24
months plus six more 30
months the kids are going to deal man
you could dig a hole in your backyard
and fill it up with mud and whipped
cream and your kids will tell that story
at your funeral more so than the trips
and soccer games you think they got to
have what they need is two parents that
don't know anybody anything and their
heart rates stay below 70 all the time
and they sleep all night and they love
each other and there is peace in that
home give them that that not
balance thanks for the call Ryan hang on
the line we're going to gift you every
dollar this is the ramsy
[Music]
show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from Church
Hill gives you an advantage over those
other guys go to Churchill mortgage.com
today to learn
[Music]
more
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John deloney
if you enjoy this show in any capacity
which the charts tell us that you guys
are liking what you hear you love
hearing the stories from the callers the
inspiration sometimes you know the tough
love please consider liking the show
consider subscribing leave us a review
wherever you're listening hit the follow
button share it with a friend text the
family group chat and let people know
hey I'm into the show I think you would
like it too and you never know how they
could get someone started on their
journey to Wellness whether it's
Financial relational or career related
thanks for doing that Richard joins us
up next in Buffalo New York Richard
welcome to the
show hey thanks for having me thanks uh
for taking my question I really
appreciate it absolutely how can John
and I
help uh so I'm a 24y old old former uh
children's Pastor I had to uh resign
under duress uh I'm going through a
divorce right now I have you know
$42,000 uh in debt between student loans
and maxed out credit card debt and I
just need to know want to know uh if
it's possible to get out of this hole of
course it's possible what
happened um so at the at the job uh due
to my wife's mental Health she she's
struggling with bipolar disorder
borderline personality disorder um and
uh there was an incident uh allegedly
where I was physically pushed in a
private meeting um and so I had to to
take off um and then a lot of the debt I
can't say all of it I wish I could uh
the credit card debt was a lot of um you
know medical medical debt you know just
trying to survive uh at a 26k salary so
it wasn't a whole lot to work with um
but uh she requested the divorce uh
shortly thereafter uh and so now I'm
back home trying to figure things out
trying to rebuild my life gotcha well I
hate that you went through all that um I
can assure you there's light on the
other side of this
okay and um apprciate that
uh you could go work at McDonald's and
make more than $26,000 right now so this
is not this is not an economic issue I
think you're going to have to be wring
with the identity part because in your
head you are a quote unquote pastor and
you are a quote unquote CH childhood
expert and you are quote unquote married
and now you're none of those things yeah
and so I think the moment the first time
we think we've got this identity wrapped
up and especially when it's a job title
um and the first time it gets ripped
away from us or we get opportunity to do
something else it's
unmingled it away out from under us and
we're falling right you're not what I
want to challenge you Joe's going to
walk I mean George's going to walk you
through the the the financial part of
this but here's what I want to challenge
you go do something
tomorrow
okay the challenge is for you not to sit
at home in
wallow another another job will come
whether that's a pastor's job whether
that's working with kids um you can go
be a school teacher and double your
salary tomorrow right you can get a job
starting in the second semester you may
I never want to see another kid again as
long as I live what who knows but I want
you to
go call a Christmas tree farm call
McDonald's call Subway get a job
tomorrow okay yeah start getting some
income in your home and start having a
thing that you need to go do and work
towards do not don't quote unquote
Follow Your
Passion you need a job yeah okay let's
start loving people taking care of them
wherever you happen to be because that's
who you are
and then in the process we'll heal from
this divorce we'll heal from this the
things that were said if you were in the
home with somebody with bipolar disorder
or with unmanaged borderline personality
disorder you've been through hell and
back
right yeah yeah I um yeah and then your
church turns on you and that feels
unmingled so let's talk Monty Richard
you're living with your parents right
now is that right yes yes I am rentree
because my mom is the best wonderful God
bless moms so what are your expenses
have you actually looked at what it
takes to run Richard's life right now
per
month yes uh yes I have what does that
amount
to so uh you know thankfully my my
salary kind of limited my poor decisions
uh so at the bare minimum there silver L
not always not always
Richard yeah yeah no I honestly I'm I'm
thankful for it because if I if I had
more money I probably would have been in
this exact spot but way worse uh so uh
with everything and it's it's uh I have
a car payment uh my minimum credit card
payment is uh 365 you know AAA my phone
um and I'm trying to Door Dash on the
side once I get you know I'm hoping to
get a little more minimum wage but it
takes about uh 1,500 a month at the bare
minimum if I'm just paying minimum
payments to to run my life even without
the rent so 15500 is the number we're
aiming at just to kind of cover your
basis uh that yeah that would be like I
would be netting like zero got it um
yeah so beyond that if we can make more
than that that can all go towards paying
extra on our smallest
debt yes do you have any money in the
bank right
now uh that's not the reaction you want
to hear laughter Okay so 26 Grand George
yeah well that helps me just go all
right our A1 is getting a $1,000 starter
emergency fund so before we start
tackling the debt just keep the minimum
payments going when you get that job
tomorrow your A1 build $1,000 that's it
okay after that debts no ball smallest
to largest debts in order we're going to
attack the little one with a Vengeance
make small make minimum payments on the
rest and uh you can do this this is a
fixable problem cuz you're about to get
a raise no matter what job you get you
just got a raise so that's the good news
and if you can make let's say 40 50
Grand working a few jobs over the next
12 months could you put 20K at this debt
in a
year yeah I mean I I you know I don't I
don't see any reason why not I I've been
crunching the numbers I can tell you why
I can tell you why
ego yeah because I want to move out of
my parents house because I want to be a
minister and not be able to eat but
that's what I want to do and it's it's
going to be
ego ego if you sit down with your mom
tonight and say mom I want to make a
12-month commitment to you I got to get
this stuff paid off you're not going to
see me much you might see remnants of me
coming and going like a ghost but I'm
going to work seven jobs I have to be
done with this
madness when you're 25 you're going to
stand six inches taller than you do
right
now because you got you the nail on the
head I I thought I was just going to get
financial advice for your preaching to
me no dude cuz dude this isn't that you
knew the math was bad you made 26 Grand
a year that's what my son makes cleaning
horse dolls in the woods not really it
doesn't make anywhere close to that but
good God 26 Grand in New York geez
Louise I I did get housing at the time
so that helped uh but I have I have
golly the thought that just came in my
head I'm glad I didn't say because they
would have been diving for the dump
button back there and it would have got
me cancelled
that is what people use sometimes to
give people unlivable
wages it's cruel okay and you're a good
man and you're young and you wanted to
get in foot in the door and partridge in
a PA fore y yada y go get several jobs
what's the car loan what's left on
that I I got it last year um when I got
into like a head-on collision uh so it's
um the monthly payment is um 450 and
total uh it is
18,000 that is a lot of car even for a
guy who was making 26 is the car worth
still thankfully yes yes it is it's only
got like 40,000 miles on it is that part
of your 42k in debt or is that extra on
top of the student loans and the credit
cards that are maxed out that would be
that would be extra actually yeah I
think this car needs to go my man it's
gone this weekend can you borrow mom's
car to get to and from
work um her cars are in really bad shape
she's not as bad as your financial shape
oh yeah that is that is true that is
true and it's the thing that I'm worried
about and this is I think because I I've
been talking to my friends and they all
say the same thing but I I think an
expert opinion will put me at ease what
I'm worried about is selling the car and
getting uh like cuz I don't mind what I
drive I really don't care I'll drive a A
can wheel what are you worried about
Richard go we're up to the clock
wor about if I if I get a 100K mile car
that get over yourself hom my truck has
200,000 with a two and it's awesome it's
not that awesome actually at all but it
works Richard you know what to do man
this you got to stop making excuses and
just move forward with your life thanks
for the call that puts this hour of the
ramsy show in the
books
[Music]
oh
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George Campbell joined
by my good friend Dr John deloney and we
are here for you America to give you a
little bit of Hope in a world that feels
a little hopeless to give you a little
bit of Peace in a world that feels
chaotic whether that's with your money
your relationships your mental health
you know name it the number to call is
5225 Caleb kicks us off in Indianapolis
Caleb welcome to the Ramsey Show hi
thank you for having me sure um so uh
back uh last end of 2022 um I went uh
through a
divorce and following up that divorce I
got into the gambling addiction um got
into it pretty bad I got I kept it a
secret from family friends and and
everybody and um fast forward to about
February after I sold the house and
stuff I uh reached out to my parents and
let them know that my situation um I
came clean with my debt and and told
them the amount that I had and all that
and they got me onto this program called
Green Path Financial which is like a
thatb consolidation they consolidate
with your creditors oh jeez and they
tried to lower the interest rates on um
on your loans so I went on that program
for about 10 months now and um I
finished my college uh fortunately with
my last marriage I did get free tuition
with my uh degree so I do not have any
student loan
payments um I got a new job down here in
Indianapolis I move three hours south of
my own even with this debt um got quite
a bit of of pay
raise so even budgeting I thought I
would uh be able to tackle this on my
own and unfortunately you know few weeks
ago I um got right back into the
gambling addiction again and
I'm uh finally reached out to my parents
and I also have a girl for now five
months and I've lied to her for five
months about um my current situation and
not telling her about the gambling and
at first I told her it was only like
$6,000 and then I came clean two weeks
later said no it's really like $20,000
and then I really wasn't being honest
and I finally told her a few days ago
that it was amount of
$35,000 and she's is very hurt by it I'm
hurt by it my family's hurt by it so um
I to reach out to the hotline to seek
help for myself um and tried talking to
the therapists about it and I guess you
know I'm trying to move forward I'm kind
of behind on things I'm just trying to
get back of my feet you know and most of
my support is you know three hours away
so as far as that go I'm not sure what
to do moving forward or what suggestions
you guys may have did you keep your job
man yes I still my job are you still
going every day yep okay
um are you ready to be
done oh I'm done I know but you said
that last time are you ready to be done
I'm ready to be done okay what steps did
you take in order to be done I called
the hotline and I and I told him I need
help what kind of gambling was
this uh online yeah Black Jack have you
disconnected your I your internet from
your home
no that's all tied into my R it's it
used to be separate but now it's not
have you got rid of a computer so you
have no access I don't have a computer
it could be done on the mobile phone I I
was going to get to your mobile phone
next but here's what I'm saying you've
destroyed your life
once you've done it
again and until you get really serious
about it and take away access and not
just the hotline is great it's really
important but you need to go to a
meeting
tomorrow or if you can find a ga meeting
uh tonight go
tonight okay because you got you got
nobody in your corner man and um it
doesn't map right on top of it but I
like the idea doesn't work a dollar for
dollar if you will but the idea that
addiction is often connection related or
disconnection related you got
nobody right right and the person you
did have is now
very disconnected from you because you
didn't tell the
truth right right and she's still scking
by my side right now I know she did I
know she did but there's a gap between
you and you know that you can feel it
right but here's the deal when I ask you
if you're all in if you're ready you got
to be all in and if that means getting a
flip phone for a while and not having
internet access
great if that means for a season um I've
deleted every app off my phone and my
wife has a mirror app or my girlfriend
has a mirror app or whoever my
accountability partner is great and I'm
going to go to a meeting at 6:00 a.m.
I'm go to another one at 7 p.m do you
have time for that nope but you don't
have time to keep drowning
either right and she's in the opposite
situation as me she's you know got 300
plus thousand in net worth great we're
not we're not having we're not playing
comparison game we're trying to survive
right because that comparison game for
somebody in your situation is a shame
Factory you don't need that right now
you got have shame as it is
right you need to sit in a room with
other men and women who are in the same
pocket of hell that you're in and feel
them go yeah me too man right that's it
and if you don't take it this seriously
you're gonna be right back in the same
situation your girlfriend's going to
leave and you're going to ow $65,000
instead of
$35,000 correct online Sports gambling
is a cancer in our country and you got
it correct is there more debt Caleb no
that that is me coming quean that is
everything what are you what are you
making your job about 70,000 a year okay
and what is this $35,000 in debt made up
of uh just combination of credit cards
have you cut up all of your credit cards
because that's one of the reasons you
keep going back here all the accounts
are closed okay I have no access to any
the accounts that was part of the
agreement when I joined the debt
consolidation
program so is this all one giant debt
now that you're working on correct okay
what's the interest rate on
this um they vary between 3% up to 9%
they um have one card that's at 9% but
they say once 18 month of payments have
been completed they will drop it to zero
so okay well I want you to attack this
aggressively regardless of the interest
rate you've got one mountain de climb
and that's his $35,000 debt you make 70k
can you work on top of
that yes because if we can get any extra
income we can get rid of this debt
within 18
months is that fair you have any money
right now anywhere else you can
liquidate or sell stuff U that was a
question I was going to ask um I have a
70 Camaro that my uh dad and I did 10
years ago he's it's in his name now but
he's giving it to me to get my kid
someday in the future but he says no
you're not selling it so what's your
thoughts on that CU he wanted me to ask
too I probably wouldn't sell it I mean
right now what you're trying to do is
you're trying to get
Band-Aids o over cancer you can't do
that
correct I'd rather see the behavior
change yeah when you feel that with your
future income and you see all that money
disappearing towards lenders it's going
to be a stark reminder of why you're
never going to get back here again what
do you do for a living brother I'm a
senior assist administrator cool so you
can drive in the morning and you can do
your job in the during the day and then
in the evening you can drive again or
you can go throw boxes at a Walmart
until 11:
p.m. gotta if you're working like mad a
you don't have time to be on your phone
gambling and two you cannot do this by
yourself you have to get a group that
meets in person and you'll sit around a
circle and look at each other and be
honest period you can get out of this in
18 months probably quicker than that if
you want to work and if you want to be
committed to getting well um hang on the
line we're going to send you building a
non-anxious life my new
[Music]
book
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys it's Rachel Cruz it's open
enrollment season so it's a great time
to explore your health care options for
next year if you feel tied down by your
budget check out Christian Healthcare
Ministries chm is not health insurance
it's a faith-based health cost sharing
Ministry that has helped members take
care of nearly 10 billion do in
healthcare costs chm is an affordable
alternative to insurance that gives you
the freedom and empowers you to live out
your values and you can join at any time
so find out more at chministries.org
[Music]
budget
this is the ramsy show I'm George camel
joined by Dr John deloney we've got a
special show coming up in December here
in a few weeks we're going to be doing
the giving edition of the Ramsey Show
it's one of our favorites of the year
and we want to hear stories from you
guys about how you have given generously
this season maybe you tipped a waitress
a hundred bucks you bought Thanksgiving
dinner for a family who couldn't afford
it maybe you blessed someone in need by
giving them a car who knows maybe you
were on the receiving end of all this
and you had your life Changed by someone
who gave generously to you we want to
hear those stories here's what you need
to do go to ramseys solutions.com askk
and put giving in the subject line it's
coming up on December 18th so start
sending in your stories of giving today
and let's celebrate living like no one
else so you can give like no one else
ramsy solutions.com
askk Sam is up next in San Francisco Sam
what's going on
hi happy Friday and Merry Christmas um
you as well my question is my thanks my
question is regarding my disability
insurance um I have own occupation
disability which made sense when I was
single when I finished all my training I
had
$458,000 in student loans um I've been
paying I was paying about 3,000 a month
on them I'm recently married um we've
combined bank accounts income and debt
we're in baby step to on the one hand
it's only been a few months and I'm just
really frustrated with what I feel is
our lack of progress which probably
isn't as bad as I think it is but I
would like to redirect that 450 a month
to the debt on the other hand um I feel
like it's irresponsible to cancel it
because if I get hit by a bus tomorrow
um my student loan companies won't care
my loans are the bulk of our debt and we
would definitely struggle struggle on
one income but if if you die your
student loans die with you don't they
yeah but if I'm just disabled they don't
okay so if I a limb um so I don't know
if should I cancel it what's itting
right now out of pardon me what's it
cost right now it's like around 450 a
month but it goes up every year it's
$450 a
month yes is this shortterm or longterm
no it's longterm that feels real high
for longterm mine is like 12 12 bucks
yeah mine's Well mine's own occupation
so it's it's specific for
what what do you do yeah I'm a
surgeon that explains it uh well there
there's a reason it's higher and that's
because there's a higher chance that it
could happen in your occupation and
there's a bigger income to cover as well
what do you
make um it's highly variable um because
I'm pure commission right now I'm
probably bringing in around 12,000 a
month after taxes okay um but I'm
actually also about to in the next next
couple months I'm leaving my job and
starting my own practice which will give
me a huge hit and so I'm also looking at
how that's going to impact our budget
and where that like 450 goes have you
resho this insurance in a while with an
independent broker I would at least do
that to make sure you're getting a uh
the best deal possible for a great
coverage what is it how much does it
cover as far as your salary what
percentage it's actually two policies
one of them is like up until 65 and then
one of them is Lifetime and when I I
kind of did reshop it like right before
I finish all my training and he said
keep the lifetime because they don't
offer that anymore so I think the
lifetime is
1,500 and then the other one is 2500 so
it's a total of 4,000 a month um and
then like 1,500 of that is good for
Lifetime and the rest would drop off at
65 I don't know that you'll need the I
know but it covers it covers my minimum
payment so but if you're retired at 65
you're not going to need that anymore
true so I I know it they may not do it
anymore but I also think it's also not
super helpful so if you want to cut down
the cost I would cut that one and I
would also reshop it with an independent
broker but no I would not cut this out
of your life to get out of debt faster
uh insurance is too important especially
in your field and disability long-term
disability is one of those that we
recommend for everyone and Ramsey
thankfully covers that for for our team
but because of your occupation I know
it's pricier and it stinks to pay that
out but it also stinks to pay my auto
insurance and my life insurance and my
health insurance but goodness we're glad
we have it when life hits the fan what
kind of what kind of surgeon are you
yeah pardon me what kind of surgeon are
you um Plastics okay um I know I'm
underpaid that's why I'm starting my own
I was gonna say my goodness I know and
you do elective Plastics but you also do
reconstructive Plastics and so you more
than anybody know
I do yeah life happens to people yeah I
know I actually do mostly mostly
constructive but so I'm saying like if
anybody knows like I should probably
keep this insurance it's you because
it's easy for the average person to go
through life and be like I'm not going
to get in a car wreck I'm not going to
fall off a bike I'm not g to get bit by
a whatever and that's all you do every
day you
know yeah no yeah but I can't I can't
wrap my head
around I mean that's that's not even
that's not halfway to gen PRACK money
these
days I know I know it's h you know there
there was a lot going like it's and it's
even now like I'm not going great full
see but it's scary it's scary to go out
on your own at least like I'm married
now my husband's incredibly supportive
and so I like somebody to like support
me but it's it's terrifying and I've
been putting it off for a good five
years is there another is there another
group you can go work
with
n no not for what I do my goodness okay
not going to get any better
yeah I I mean I'm I'm I trust you
because this is your field I'm stunned
at how long no I looked into it actually
I looked into I did a lot um I I did a
lot of you know kind of read entree
leadership book and spent like a really
really long time like exploring two
different options just like months and
finally I just kind of a bunch of things
lined up and I think there was also a
huge component you know I always felt
like God would tell me when it was time
to go and he just like just a million
things lined up and it was loud and
clear and he was like it's time so so
help me through the specialty things the
stuff real quick because I've got
friends that are nurse practitioners
that make
that how hard is it to
pause being dramatically underpaid for
what you're doing and go over to another
another vertical in
medicine very incred it's impossible you
you'd have to redo a residency okay all
right right so I'm actually resident I'm
actually like I'm I've done residency
I've done a fellowship I've done that's
why I've got such like that's why my
loans are so high because actually I
didn't I finished my school with under
with under 400 but then like interest
occurred because that was kind of or
planning on my part so that's why I end
up with 458 because I deferred for for
quite a bit of time so what's the total
Deb load you guys
have
um it is currently
463,000 oh my goodness is that include a
mortgage or is that all the nope that's
all the consumer stuff from school
that's it's my you got cars in there his
One loan we have one car and we just
paid off his um his car we have his
daughter's car we paid off his car this
week so um and then there's a little bit
of um little bit of IRS in there okay
well with your current take home pay
this is going to take a Lifetime and so
to John's point we have to dramatically
increase the income that's the problem
right now we got a huge hole we have a
decent shovel but not compared to the
hole so that's going to be your key out
of here and canceling the insurance to
make a few extra hundred bucks is not
going to be the ticket out
either so but I I'd keep looking in the
in the couch cushions of your budget to
see where else you can cut to make some
meaningful impact but the income is
where you're going to be able to knock
this debt out in the next you know four
or five years if you can start throwing
you know 70 80 grand of your take-home
pay at this debt it's a different
equation what's your husband do he's in
sales does he have an opportunity to
significantly increase his
salary um yes yeah and he's been working
on that he's actually very good at what
he does so again like his because he's
in sales his his income is also
incredibly variable so it's the the
budgeting thing has been also are the
first time in my life i' ever done the
budget yeah we can tell we can tell well
you guys are also in the Bay Area
which not helping yes we are what's
what's your mortgage or
rent um
2900 okay that's reasonable I thought I
was going to have a heart attack it's
actually it's actually no it's actually
like stupidly low and that's actually
one of the issues is that I'm actually
it's complicated but we're we're going
to have to move because it's just not a
sustainable like I I moved into his
bachelor pad so it's G to have to go up
but well there's a whole lot that's
unsustainable right now and half a
million dollars of debt is a bigger
problem than moving into the pad so I
wish you the best in increasing this
income and getting rid of half a million
dollars in debt our friend Jade warshaw
did it if you need some inspiration and
motivation check out her book money's
not a math problem that puts this
segment in the books we'll be right
[Music]
back
I'm George camel joined by Dr John
deloney this is the ramsy show the
number to call Triple
5225 today's question of the day is
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services when you want to repair
maintain or improve your home stop
wasting time scrolling through pages and
pages of providers neighborly is all you
need to remember for a nationwide
network of local Home Service
professionals visit neighbor.com Ramsey
to find Reliable help near you today's
question comes from Jim in Ohio Jim asks
my wife and I decided not to use credit
cards prior to marriage she decided to
use one of her cards behind my back and
is now $6,000 in debt she has $6,000 in
savings from a settlement to pay it off
but will not your
thoughts my thoughts Jim are that this
is not about using money X to pay off
debt y this is about you and your wife
had a set of values and your wife lied
to your face this is not about using
settlement X to pay off debt y this is
about your wife committing Financial
infidelity she cheated on you y all
agreed we're not going to do this she
did
that's what you'll have to deal with
because you deal with that issue then
the what do we do next is anything if
somebody cheats on their spouse and like
with another romantic partner and they
choose to stay together the question is
often like what do we do now we're going
to do anything it takes everything it
takes you just have to have the harder
conversation which is your marriage is
in a lot of trouble and this is one of
the reasons John that we recommend
people combin bank accounts have total
visibility in communication when it
comes to money cuz my guess is says they
never really combined finances she's
doing her thing over here well she has
this 6K in settlement she has this debt
she won't pay it off we need to have an
hour discussion a Wei discussion where
we go we have 6,000 in savings we now
have $6,000 in debt how are we going to
solve this and how do we prevent this
from ever happening again and if she
says no no no no I have
$6,000 your marriage is in trouble
period Y and I know the internets don't
like that and I know the modern
marriage is stupid it's an old archaic
Relic it's you're you're look around
look around at our culture you're yeah
you're showing us great job guys it is
critically important and you got to be
Allin if both of you aren't Allin well
then the whole thing caves in on itself
part of being Allin is saying our money
our debt our home not my check goes in
my account to pay my bills well then
you're glorified roommates and
and you did that in college with want to
go back to that yeah why disgusting why
well sorry you're dealing with that Jim
but uh it sounds like it's a good
opportunity to reset this marriage and
go we're going to go differently forward
and communicate differently we're going
to have different set of values and
we're going to freeze our credit bureau
account so that we can't go into Deb if
we wanted to put some process in place
and figure out what was at the root of
her going into debt behind your back
that's the real issue at hand here all
right let's get to the phones Marie is
in Jacksonville Marie what's going on
hey um so I just out of the blue was
laid off
um I know I am a um big every dollar
user have been for a while I try to St
very regimented I am still only on baby
step to um but I'm really struggling
with making my budget now I am not quite
sure what to do and it's not I'm I'm
definitely trying to get a job I'm
definitely working on it um and I guess
the biggest question that I have is I
did kind of Veer off from the plan a
little bit because I I didn't feel
secure with $1,000 as my buffer so I
actually have $5,000 as a
buffer okay so I I I don't know my
comfort level with letting go of that
5,000 Marie you're
unemployed I don't know if it's about
being comfortable it's about
surviving
yeah how much debt do you
have um I am I know this is going to
sound funny but I'm down to um 15 in
like loans and credit cards and about
110 on my mortgage okay so mortgage
aside you have we have $15,000 of debt
to clean up before we can move on to
baby step three and four and five and
all of that right okay and how much were
you what were you making before you got
laid off
I was around I was take home I was
taking home
about just under 6,000 a month nice what
were you
doing um running a charter school that's
a big job how you why' you get laid
off um really it was a personality
conflict with my boss and I I uh I had
no writeups no warnings no bad
performance reviews nothing it was just
I know you don't want to work here and I
don't want you to work here either so
goodbye wow but so the other side of
that is there are a few Industries
starving for educators more than the
education profession right can you have
a job by January heading into another
school even if it's not your ideal job I
don't want this job but it's a job and
you're going to do a great
job yeah and that's what I'm working on
I actually am hoping to get one that
will start at the end of January okay um
that's a bigger like more of a career
thing but um I am looking at like
temporary hold over like you know
seasonal anything but I also want you at
McDonald's yeah I mean like you need a
job right yeah you need a job and I
think I think it's easy to be like I'm
an educator I'm an administrator this is
what I do I'm I'm a Headmaster well
you're
like you got to get a job right we need
some money right right so in the
meantime let's pick up some of the
holiday retail Hospitality shifts so
that you can keep your your home afloat
what are your monthly expenses right
now um monthly expenses I am oh gosh
it's pretty heavy but I've already gone
through um I'm actually like looking at
my every dollar right now on my computer
but um I would say that I've got I mean
I've gone through and reduced everything
that I could possibly do I've reached
out to like my self phone company and
they actually gave me a credit for a
month um I've reached out to my son's
daycare and they're helping me out I've
reached out to my auto insurance
adjusted a little bit of the rates but
not the property damage because I can't
let go of at least having enough to
cover a car if God forbid there's an
accident but I've reduced that to bring
down my um insurance payment by about
$100 a month so we talking 4,000 a month
would run the house what's the number
now that youve
I would say about 4,000 okay well even
with this uh over indexed starter
emergency fund you're only going to last
a month here yeah and so that scares me
on top of are you a single mom yes I am
okay that scares me even more and so we
need to get a job probably two or three
ASAP in order to keep the lights on keep
them at daycare so you can be at work
for 50 60 hours a week until we get back
to that dream job or that job in your
profession back to making 6 grand a
month take home cuz then this debt going
to be paid off soon it's not really a
debt problem here uh so as far as budget
right now it is four walls it's food
utilities shelter Transportation
insurance that is it everything else you
can survive without for a month or two
or three right so stinks you're going
through take it out of that emergency
fund though you don't have another
option yeah right now this is it I would
try to not touch that I would go get a
job and try to create $4,000 of income
in the next 30 days to cover this um but
in the meantime if you absolutely need
to yes step into the emergency fund the
key is don't go further into debt
compounding the problem how old are your
kids right five just five we
we've I don't recommend any of these
things I'm saying I'm just saying some
of the creative things that we've seen
on the show where people will put their
5-year-old and I made that number up but
put their young child in the backseat of
a car and they'll listen to books on CDs
or through like audible or something
like that they will sing and they will
deliver
food because that's what they have to do
and this is not how you drew this up but
this is where you find yourself my fear
for you is it sounds like um yeah it was
time this hurts and this stings and it's
the freaking holidays this is not the
moment for the mom of a 5-year-old to
not have a job I mean it's hard right
it's scary I don't want that to turn
into inertia and turn into well I'm
going to find this fancy job go get a
couple of jobs right now and and it's
just ego's got to go out the door is
about survival for the next 60 days 90
days the other job will come and Marie
hang on the line I'm going to take one
less expense out of your life we're
going to pay for one year of every
dollar premium so that you can get on a
plan and get through this season thanks
for the call this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show
yeah
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George camel joined by Dr John delone
here's a friendly reminder that we are
located just south of Nashville
Tennessee here at the Ramsey Solutions
headquarters and we love having guests
visit us we've got some lovely folks
from all over the country even met a
nice fellow from Sweden John guy's
amazing incredible amazing and so uh you
are welcome to show up you can watch the
show live you can get free fresh baked
cookies and and lattes and all of that
we've got a bookstore there's a little
Museum timeline wall we made it a really
fun experience if you want to pop
through if you're in town for some
reason or nearby we'd love to have you
during the holidays Caitlyn joins us up
next in Sacramento California Caitlyn
what's going
on hi George hi Dr John thank you so
much for taking my
call absolutely um I just have a quick
question I am currently in baby step
number two I'm working on my debt
snowball and I have a good old Sally May
loan that my dad co-signed on with me
and I'm just curious my dad's been
asking me about it and I'm still trying
to work through my snowball I have a
couple smaller things ahead of it but
since he's been asking me about it he's
asked me to make it a priority in paying
that off so I just wanted your guys's
opinion on if I should move that up in
my dead snowball knock it out and then
go back the way it's intended or have a
conversation with my dad let him know
what my estimated timeline is and go
from
there where does it currently fall in
the Deb
snowball um I have a I have about two um
smaller credit cards in front of it so
when do you think you get there is this
like six months from
now um yeah I was thinking July or
August just depending on bonuses from
work and things like that that's when
you start on that
debt that's when I would be done with
paying that debt off okay I would
communicate that with him and say Hey
Dad I'm following this plan this is a
proven plan that I know is going to get
me out of debt I'm very committed to
this I commit to paying off this debt
that I took out even though you signed
it and here's here's the date I plan on
why is he being why does what why does
he being dramatic about
it well so he actually also follows you
guys and he did the Financial Peace
University at our church when I was in
high school and um since then he had
paid off all of his debt and then fell
back into it and so he's trying to work
on his stuff while I work on mine and he
just wants to make sure all of his you
know tees are crossed and eyes are
dotted he's taking out his um shame and
angst on
you he made a he made a decision that he
knew at the moment he was doing it was
gonna get was going to create a rift in
your relationship with him and by the
way I put this on the parents 100% of
the time you're a kid not your job to
manage your parents it's your job to
push up against boundaries and see if
they hold you did and his boundaries he
caved he SK cosigned and he feels
embarrassed and stupid about it he used
to teach people to never do that and he
did it and now he's trying to make
himself feel better by weighing on
you because he has like a context I
would tell him Dad I'm following this
plan to a te I'll have you paay off in
June or July
yeah and I wouldn't have any more
conversation my friend Jefferson fiser
we talk about all the time there is
power in the pause the person who talks
last loses this is the
conversation Tada I will have you paid
off in
July gotcha but when you say that
Caitlyn that's your word that's your
integrity on the line and so you better
have that thing paid off by
July that's going to light a fire under
you to get paid off early shock him it's
going to be May and you're going to be
like here Dad it's gone here's the
letter it's paid
off but right now this is hurting the
relationship and that's one of the
reasons one of the many reasons we tell
family members never to co-sign debt for
other family members it always hurts the
relationship well and in this particular
situation tell me if I'm wrong I don't
talk bad about your dad he's on the
phone but it sounds like he is using
this as a vehicle for hurting the
relation just it seems like there's no
reason for this to hurt the relationship
right
now
yeah it wasn't ever like he didn't bring
it up to me with any malicious intent we
have a pretty good
relationship um he just you know we i' I
talked to him because I have him as a
partner in this and um I've talked to
him about my debt snowball and he talked
to me about his and I just um brought up
that I had this student loan still
outstanding and he was he didn't bring
it up pushy or anything like that he was
just you know this was when we when he
signed it for me he signed it with you
know I graduated last um June June
2022 and um he said that you know it
would be a priority he would coign as
long as it was a priority after I
graduated regardless of the student loan
pause and all of that um because it's
private so he just said you know this is
your priority after you graduate and so
since then I've been working on um
following you guys your guys's plan the
Deb snowball all of that it's coming up
it's you know it's not too far away so
he was just it was more so of like a
reminder like hey you said this would be
a priority oh I think you tell
absolutely it is it's just yeah in the
right order so it's a it's very much a
priority you want it to be priority
number one for me it's priority number
three but it's a priority we will get it
taken care of our promise yeah that's
it's easy as that for call I'm glad to
know he's not hassling you it doesn't
sound like he's a bad guy it sounds like
he's just he had a picture of what
priority meant and you had a picture of
what priority meant and y'all just need
to align that that's good all right
let's move on to Matt in Charlottesville
Virginia Matt what's going
on hey guys thanks for taking my call
sure all right so um kind of just
discovered this whole thing uh about a
couple months ago and I've you know on
baby step 2 me and my wife um got about
$400,000 in in debt right now is that
Consumer Debt or does that include your
mortgage uh well we have a a home equity
line credit um and the rest of it's
Consumer Debt credit cards cars a boat
jet skis just a bunch of you know stupid
purchases I've made over the over the
years all right how can we help all
right so um like I said we're on we're
on baby set too um I'm just trying to
figure out where do I start if I if I
need to you know sell a couple things
that that we don't necessarily need but
we like um a lot of things a lot of
things I think everything can go at this
point pretty much all of it I think you
stop liking them when they become a
burden in your life because you can't
afford the payments and you don't even
get to enjoy them you owe half a million
dollars in your houses on the Block you
sell
everything yeah I mean so we can I can
afford the payments technically right
it's just don't care about the payments
when we started doing this yeah when we
started doing this it's just you know
you look at that amount of debt you're
like holy crap please tell me you guys
make a buttload of
money so yeah I mean I I make around
$118,000 a month my wife makes around
$4,000 a month so um is that gross so
you're making 22k gross per
month that's take home yeah after taxes
take home okay yep well that helps
that's a good salary but you're not
setting the world on fire no exactly
yeah like I said I see that amount of
debt I'm like holy cra trucks go boat
goes jet Skys go when you get out of
debt and then you can afford these
things you can go back and buy them with
cash but you can't I mean you can't
afford them they're depreciating assets
that are that are making you you guys
make too much money to be this broke
yeah no doubt and you can buy them with
cash later on at a discount cuz you're
about to sell these at a discount so you
know that good and well my friend so how
quickly here's the thing you can wait
and keep all of your toys and you can
pay off $400,000 in debt making you know
you guys make 260 take home home if you
put 10 my guess is though you you have
$155,000 in expenses every
month um yeah it's a lot so then you
only have five or six left over to throw
at the debt and you got 400 man I mean
do simp simple math you're a smart guy
it's going to take forever at this rate
and that's why we're telling you hey if
you can sell off $150,000 worth of this
stuff and have 250 to stare down and be
throwing 15,000 at it and be living off
of five to cover your household expenses
now we start to get this ball rolling I
want to see you out of this debt in two
or three
years right yeah that's that's kind of
what I thought just I need to get my
wife pully on board with it but yeah so
the way you do that is you sit down with
your wife and not like here's the plan
we're going to do you sit down with your
wife and say I'm so scared I can't
breathe will you go with me on an
adventure for a couple of years so we
can get this family to be safe cuz right
now we're not
safe thanks for the call man sorry you
guys are going through this but it's a
solvable problem but it's going to take
some sacrifice that puts this hour of
the ramsy show in the books my thanks to
my co-host Dr John deloney all the folks
in the booth and you America will'll be
back before you know
[Music]
it
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions it's the Ramsey show where we
help people build wealth do do work that
they love and create amazing
relationships I'm George camel joined by
Dr John deloney this hour and it's a
free call at triple
8825 5225 you dial those digits and we
can get you on the line and help you
with whatever conundrum life has thrown
at you maybe you just need some
confirmation to take the right next step
with a little more confidence we can
help you there Veronica starts us off
this hour in Sacramento Veronica what is
happening with
you hi uh a lot a lot I need some help
we can do that what's give me some more
specifics okay
so I've had a pretty crazy life but um
I'm a young mom I have four kids married
um crazy up until now I feel like I
finally got to the point where I've I've
created some stability which is
fantastic um however I have built a lot
of debt uh and I came up with this or I
have this opportunity to buy my home
that I'm currently in my parents had
bought it with the ideal that one day
when my husband and I are ready our
credits ready our incomes ready we can
take over the mortgage by this house
however
my uh parents have said you know what
they want to buy other properties they
have a lot of stuff they want to do they
would like me to take it over within a
calendar year
now my credit's kind of in the tanker
strictly because really high credit
usage I have 100% um payment
history um but everything is maxed out
and I'm pay all my bills on time but I
have really high interest rates on
everything and I just can't seem to get
out of it and I'm getting really
concerned that I will not be able to
take over this mortgage because my
credit will not be up to par in time I
don't think credit is the issue here I
think the issue is that you're broke and
you're not ready to be a homeowner and
this opportunity is really just a curse
and
disguise okay or think about this
opportunity as a light on your dashboard
telling you that you're at of
gas yeah the issue is your car's out of
gas not that there's a light
on
so the cor I mean I'm going to give you
a little bit of backing on the on the
house the current mortgage value is at
400,000 and it's currently valued at
about 630,000 my father's willing to
give this to me I guess and correct me
if I'm incorrect but there's some way to
sell to your child that you can sell at
their current mortgage value I don't
know there's a whole thing he wants to
do and pretty much give me this you know
200 Grand in equity he's saddling you
with
$400,000 of
debt right so you hold on make a
substantial amount of money I need to
figure out how to pay off all of my debt
so that I can clear my slate and be able
to take over this mortgage I pay the
mortgage now A plus
some so are they giving you a discounted
rent no no the mortgage is about 2,600
and I pay 3,000 hey Veronica how much do
you
make um I'm well our whole household's
about 190,000 a year okay so you're with
that number you just proved my point
George's Point Dave Ramsey's Point all
of our
Point money is very rarely a math
problem yeah it's a psychology problem
and so yes you would be getting
$200,000 in Instant
Equity it doesn't matter because you
cannot control your spending actually
you can You' have chosen not to control
your
spending yeah well I feel like
I've really really
had it's hard to explain without being
able to explain to your whole P my whole
past but I I know you don't have time
but I've gotten to the point in the last
couple years where I feel like I've
reached a different point of maturity
where I'm like okay I need to you know
get my stuff together I need to get my
spending under control which admittedly
yeah yeah this last year actually I've
paid off roughly $20,000 just this last
year awesome awesome yeah so but now
there there's this time constraint and
I'm getting really worried because I
don't want to lose my house and
how I in total debt all of your debt
outside of well you don't have a
mortgage so how much all your debts all
of my debt including student loans and
medical bills it's about $100,000 okay
and you make
$190,000 yeah what's your
mortgage so the rent that we're paying
my father's 3,000 the actual mortgage
itself is 2,600 all right so that's
that's 190 minus 36 what's your
what's
uh you could pay it off in a year or get
pretty
close yeah so I just need to work that
out because my living expenses beyond my
mortgage is is
roughly
$99,000 besides my rents $9,000
how because I have um I have four kids
so groceries each each week is like $600
just groceries by
itself and um we have a long ways to go
to
9,000 $2,400 a month in
groceries yeah so hold on I have this
all written down right
here so my total current expenses with
all of my debt is roughly $122,500
minus the mortgage puts us at what
95 and so considering ing that I have
the
2400 in groceries I have our phone bill
my electricity my PG bill just the other
month was like
$800 and because they've raised the
rates consistently so what you're
telling us your life is really expensive
and I want to remind you being a
homeowner is even more expensive than
being a renter and you guys don't have
any
money and so here's the peaceful way to
do this you go to your your parents and
say hey thank you for this opportunity
but right now we can't afford it we have
a goal to pay off all of this debt then
we need to have a six-month emergency
fund then we need to save up a down
payment so that we can become homeowners
the right
way and that might mean you guys have to
go find somewhere else to rent if
they're going to need to sell this place
because they need the money but that's
the decision that they need to make yeah
that's just harder because $3,000 I'm
not going to be able to get a house here
for that I'm in Veronica you want a plus
b to equal
432 right the only path forward for you
is to own reality choose reality you
choose a life and I'm I'm using that
word intentionally and I know it's
inflammatory but I'm doing it on purpose
you're choosing a life that costs
$99,500 a month not including your house
period right that's a choice you
make yeah that's all the debt that I've
built included yeah figure out how to
get rid of but some of it starts with
trying to find every way to cut our
grocery bill in every way M we're just
not going to eat Organics we're not
going to do this we are not eating out
for one calendar freaking
year the only way George and I hear
people get out of debt like this is when
they go scorched Earth and you're trying
to well you know kind of you can't you
will stay in the same
mess same exact me you make way too much
money to not be able to afford this
house right now and you're not willing
it doesn't sound like on the phone to
say enough is enough enough is enough
I'm pouring all the alcohol out I'm
never going to a bar again I'm sober
starting now you don't want to do that
you want to be like well you know I kind
of like that you got to you got to
choose one or the other one or the other
hang on the line Veronica I'm going to
send you one year of Financial Peace
University to show you guys that Proven
[Music]
Plan
welcome back to the Ramsay show I'm
George camel joined here by my good
friend do John deloney it's a free call
at
5225 Melanie is up next in Philadelphia
let's see what Melanie has to say what's
going on hey guys thank you so much for
taking my call it's nice to talk to both
of you you as well um thank you uh so
first let me just start off my husband
and I this is the first time that're
doing a budget uh we just finished FPU
awesome step two yeah excited about that
welcome to the gang yeah yeah we're
excited about it um I'm I love Christmas
time it's my favorite time of the year
um always go all out do all the stuff
I've also put myself in debt because of
Christmas in the past um but this year I
guess it's because the first time we're
actually doing a budget I feel really
constrained this Christmas season I I
don't have the same like angst that I've
had in the past with I haven't even put
at my tree yet which is odd for me
because we always do it right after
Thanksgiving and I just can't get myself
to just be the spirit this year and I I
feel like it has to do with the fact
that we're budgeting and I'm not just
doing the whole free for all Christmas
thing and I have like super anxiety this
year and I am just I'm kind of
struggling with what to kind of do with
that where do you where do you think the
anxiety's coming from is it is it from
do it right I have anxiety anyway you
know but I just this season I'm just
like I can't get myself into the spirit
this year and and I'm looking at the
budget and we have a budget set aside
for Christmas shopping so it's not that
we don't have the money
um but something about this sh just
feels different you want to pull it
apart real
quick I'm sorry you want to pull it
quick um so this is the first time where
I've actually see where my money goes I
mean we have a lot of debt okay I have
taken on a second job um that's it right
there that's it right there you know so
anxiety is just an alarm
system and for the first time ever you
turned all the lights on in your house
and you turned all the music off to the
dance and you asked you you looked like
I always tell people step one of of
creating a world that's not so anxious
all the time a body that's not so
riddled with anxiety all the time is
choosing
reality what is the state of my marriage
what's the state of my relationship with
my kids what state of my job what's the
state of my finances you did that and
you realized my body's been trying to
get my attention for a long time because
we're not safe we owe a lot of money mhm
and so the way you used to make yourself
feel good was buying people things and
you love you're a great Gift Giver
aren't you yeah you are I try to be yeah
and now you've chosen reality and
reality is awful because the way you
gave yourself an identity was you were a
great Gift Giver except that wasn't real
money it was borrowed money yeah and now
your body feels anxious because it knows
just how bad things are there's a dollar
amount to it mhm and so I want you to
reframe it your anxiety is working
perfectly your body's working great it
knows you're not safe and now you've
just entered into a holiday where
everyone tells you you're supposed to
just go crazy and spin ah and you're
only as worth you're only worth what you
give other people and your kids are only
going to love you as much as the stuff
you buy them your kids will be so
grateful that they got a peaceful mom on
the back end of this
deal yeah so your body's working great I
think it's you
grieving I used to blow a bunch of money
and spend it like this and I'm not going
to be able do that this year cuz that
stinks it does it's not great yeah but
it's reality right yeah how much do you
owe $
24,1 154 yeah you're probably real
anxious huh yeah yeah I we've been forun
I mean we paid a few thousand of that
all okay um you know so you know we're
there I mean we know it's not is that
all Consumer
Debt uh yes that's not a house okay so
what is the two four made up of is that
a credit cards car loans student loans
are so 132,000 is student loans um
between my husband and myself um and we
have cards and credit cards okay what's
your household
income um grow or net uh net net is 144
good okay so we have a great income and
if we can I think if we sold these cars
you would have less
anxiety yeah I know I knew were going to
say that to me Merry Christmas amputate
the
Tahoe Merry Christmas well how much how
much are the car loans how what total
what do they add up to so I owe 7,000 on
one that my adult child she actually
pays that one and then I have one that's
21 and the other one is 28 okay so if I
just handed you $50,000 would it release
some of the anxiety that's on your
shoulders if I just got rid of a quarter
of your debt tomorrow yeah of course it
would I think that's part of it you need
need you need to see that there's
actually hope here cuz knocking out a
few thousand is great but when you still
have 204 to go and that's not even
including your mortgage it just feels
like a Death March and so part of
getting rid of this anxiety is knowing
this isn't going to be a 10-year Journey
for us we're going to do this in three
years cuz we make
$150,000 net bringing home $122,000 a
month and it disappears to lenders every
month that's the source of the anxiety
not the lack of presence under the tree
how old are your kids
uh I have a 23y old a 10year old and a
three-year-old so they're pretty far
apart in age they are I would take my
10-year-old
out and have
a an honest
conversation that in the past mommy's
bought a whole bunch of presents and
this year Daddy and I are going to not
owe anybody any money we're going to be
very intentional so there's going to be
fewer presents this year but we're going
to do a couple of cool things together
the three-year-old is just going to go
and then you can have that same
conversation with your old one yeah but
but being intentional again here's what
you're doing your body's craving craving
craving
Direction so giving yourself some little
wins here I had this conversation I
hated it it was hard it's a conversation
I never wanted to have with my kid cuz
my husband and I we make a ton of money
but I had it anyway because we haven't
make good Steward of this money with my
three-year-old dude you could get a
three-year-old you could wrap up
individual bags of like leaves that you
got from the yard and they'll have fun
with that great exactly um and then your
older one you can say hey we haven't um
we didn't model this well for you we
modeled how to work really hard because
we did and we modeled how to get great
jobs because we did but we did not model
how to be a good Steward of this money
and George and I are going to hook you
up with Financial Peace University for
just you guys and we're going to give
you one that you can give to your oldest
child oh that's great thanks so much but
you're gonna have like George said
you're have to get radical about it okay
but can I show you the math on this
Melanie like some napkin math will
change your life right now if you get
rid of these cars it'll take your debt
down to about 150,000 right you need to
get some beater cars of course but
150,000 in Consumer Debt you guys take
home 144 could you live off 70 and put
75 toward the debt every year yes and
that becomes we're dead free in 24
months in two years our life completely
changes and now we bring home $112,000 a
month and we don't have lenders that
have spoken for this money two years how
old are you guys um I'm 42 and my
husband's 45 that's amazing so at 44 and
47 you guys are completely debt-free
probably 6 months later 12 months later
you have a your 6 months emergency fund
will be there you'll be investing for
the future you'll be maxing out
retirement accounts you'll be covering
your kids the younger kids are they're
going to be going to college debt free
because of the sacrifices mom and dad
made this Christmas so the question is
not can we do do this until we're 44 the
question is I'm going to be 44 do I want
to be debt free when I'm 44 or not
that's the
question I think you can well George and
I both know you can because we've we've
walked that same walk and by the way
it's miserable it's so not fun I know
it's the worst it's the worst hard it's
so hard it is but I'm telling you on the
other side of one of the toughest things
I've ever had to go through and uh but a
reality check those kids man kids are
going to absorb your
tension you know what's harder is when
you call back 20 years from now and we
get this call we've gotten it this week
and the person says I'm 59 we haven't
taken care of our money and now it feels
like it's too late and we can never get
out of this they were a half million
dollars in Consumer Debt and that's
where this thing will just continue
compounding if we continue with this
outrageous spending and not getting
control and not making the sacrifices so
it's worth the side hustles is it's
worth the emptiness under the tree and
just connect as a family this year and
have the honest conversations do the
hard things and 2 years from now your
life is completely different and the
next 40 years you get Freedom that's a
good math equation that's worth it every
single time hang on the line we're going
to send you those two financial piece
universities one for you and your
husband one for the oldest kid and uh
they'll they'll start to get it Go Mom
and Dad I'm with you or cheering you
[Music]
on
[Applause]
la
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm
George Campell joined by Dr John deloney
as you head into the weekend I want to
remind you guys we have some new things
happening at ramsy solutions.com in the
store we have a great new kids book from
our friend Rachel Cruz that's
beautifully Illustrated a new book from
Jade warshaw her first book a quick read
is out called money's not a math problem
the 2024 Ramy gold planner that includes
my friend Dr John deloney and of course
my new book called breaking
from broke it is uh it's very exciting
cover John so bright some would say
jarringly bright cuz I want it to stand
out in the crowd yes and uh it's very
humorous I worked hard to make it not
only research driven but also humor
driven and there's a lot of music
references there's even three I think
three John deloney references well
that's that's why I bought it that's why
you did it John that's I bought it so if
you want to break free from this toxic
money system uh whether that's you
pointing at inflation or the guy in the
white house or it's the credit card
companies this book is going to help you
just take back control and stop pointing
fingers and just start holding up a
mirror and going how am I going to do
this how am I going to live life without
a credit score without credit card debt
without student loans how do I just live
with more freedom more margins more
options and more peace you can pre-order
it at ramsy solutions.com store and when
you do that you'll get 100 bucks worth
of bonus items for free including the
ebook the audiobook and way more let's
get to the phones Tony joins us in
Houston Texas up next Tony we love
Houston hello how you doing um not too
bad I guess I have a a question about
bankruptcy um how do you figure out when
is the best time to actually consider or
file for
bankruptcy um the current situation is I
was recently in a wreck and I pretty
much destroyed my fiance's car which she
had coverage for but both of our
insurance I had my own ins insurance too
but both of our insurance company uh had
deny coverage so now I'm stuck with an
extra car payment uh every month for a
car is not usable can't even sell it um
or if I were to sell it it would only be
worth you know roughly 2,000 or
something for the junk power that it is
now compared to the 26,000 I owe on it
so I guess uh I'm trying to figure out
when is in would be the best time to
consider bankruptcy not in this
situation
99% of people who call in saying I think
I need to file bankruptcy absolutely
don't what they really need is Hope and
a plan cuz right now life is
scary because you're broke you've got
this car situation you can't afford this
payment and you feel like there's
nowhere left to turn and so hopefully by
the end of this call we can give you a
few next steps that will help you get
out but none of it's going to be easier
fun there's no shortcuts
here right so tell us about the whole
financial picture have you uh tried to
appeal for this coverage or what was the
situation where they denied coverage
completely it was like a financial best
what it was I was excluded on her policy
for her to keep her premiums now and um
we didn't really understood what that M
meant now till now um and then my
insurance is it's it's denying covery
because that vehicle I had co-signed on
it and they considered that I am part
owner and it wasn't under my policy so
that's their loophole so both the
insurance company have their loophole
and now uh the only hope I would think
now is that I can minimize it because I
did have gap insurance on that vehicle
and got it from the
dealership but um if they deny coverage
from the gap insurance on stuff paying
this 26,000 and we had to get her a
second car which they managed to approve
and she has a second car which is now
another high payment a month so we're
making technically three car payments
now and up top of our all our other you
know rent because we rent we don't own a
home but we have our rent and our other
living expenses so you guys are living
together have you have you combined
finances or are they still
separate the the car or your bank
accounts her debt your debt your bank
her
bank yeah they're right now we have two
separate bank account but I started
putting my deposits in her bank account
so we we have our bank account and I
have my old bank account we need to keep
our life separate right now she needs to
worry about her debt you need to be
worried about your debt and now you have
this new payment on on the line here
what other debt do you
have well we have roughly about five
would say 5,000 in credit card debt okay
and then how much total in the car
debt the total Car Deb between the two
cars in my
car probably 55 ,000 maybe average total
any other
debt uh the live uh the rents uh
1150 uh probably another I want to say
maybe a th just to cover all our grocery
for the month but that's not Deb I'm
just talking about payments that you owe
outside of your rent and normal
bills right okay the besides that there
to Total monthly bills I guess would say
uh
to roughly going to be about 13,400 just
for the three car payment and then like
I said the 1150 for the rent how much
you make what's your what's your
salary well right now I just started a
new job U making more income than I did
was hoping that maybe but I make uh
15,550 an hour at roughly 40 hours a
week between 30 and 30 35 and 40 hours a
week and she makes uh I think it's 11 or
1,200 every two weeks from her
paycheck so the first thing that has to
happen and there's not really discussion
about this dude or you're going to
continue to be
underwater is you're going to have to
sell both of your cars and you're going
to have to get thousand cars that your
friends laugh at you about that's the
only chance you
got y'all cannot afford two car payments
on nice cars you don't make enough money
on top of you got a third car that you
got to pay off cuz yeah y'all got taken
advantage of man you you signed
something you didn't really understand I
hate that happened to y'all it's just
like a suck tax it just is but man um
you don't make nearly enough money well
let me say it this way George and I
don't even use car
payments I'm not going to make those
dudes rich off my back I'm just not
going to do
it and so y'all got to sell your cars
man do what you got to do and get that
get that de out of your life man got you
guys are you underwater on all three
obviously the one you are with that
lease situation the other two are they
underwater you owe more than they're
worth not yeah like no the new one
starts payments this month so we're able
to buy some time and then my other
payment starts again cuz I managed to
refinance the car cuz that bank that the
car that I total had a leon on my car
but I'm refinanced it to take the Le off
of it so they wouldn't try to repossess
it and you're current on all the
payments in your life as of right now
we're technically current all what
George means by underwater is how much
do you owe on your wife's new
car uh that loan I think was another
26,000 I believe good God how how much
is the car
worth um maybe maybe I don't know, is
relatively new a 2020
Equinox well the the goal here is that
you're not underwater meaning the car is
still worth 26 or more and you could
sell it and get out from under this
payment and get something real
cheap so you're A1 right now you need a
th000 bucks in the bank for you and
right now you guys aren't married she
needs to worry about her debt you need
to worry about your debt the goal is for
both of you to become debt free but
combining bank accounts and both you
making bad financial decisions that
you're both liable for we got quit
that no more co-signing no more
refinancing no more consolidation and my
I got a plan the only way out of this is
to get out of this and that's selling
the cars getting the income up cutting
expenses down to nothing and no more
debt just tell yourself debt is not an
option what am I going to do if debt did
not exist and that means making, 1550 an
hour and then going to Walmart after you
get off that shift in throwing boxes
until 2: a.m. and going home and
sleeping until 6:45 and being at your
job at 7:30 and doing the whole thing
over again you got to get this $26,000
car paid off you got to get some cash in
the bank but man y'all just y'all just
got to quit making these choices hang on
the line we're going to send you
Financial Peace University I want you
all two to watch these classes together
please there nine lessons that will
change your freaking life if you'll do
it do not file bankruptcy that's not the
solution to your problem thanks for the
call Tony this is the ramsy
show
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show our
scripture of the day Luke 16:10 whoever
can be trusted with very little can also
be trusted with much and whoever is
dishonest with very little will also be
dishonest with much Kyle Chandler said
opportunity does not knock it presents
itself when you beat down the door
thank you for that Kyle appreciate that
motivation Kim is up next in Baltimore
Kim what is happening in your
world hi John Hi how are you guys doing
doing well great what's up hi um I had a
question for you all um we have had um
an incredible year as far as our home
our work life and even in our um we've
taken in a beautiful Bost rido that
we'll be adopting um and we have seen
some great strides um we are just trying
trying to figure out and balance um what
is appropriate um in the financial world
for spending for Christmas to keep our
kids humble and content but also allow
them to just know how appreciative we
are what a amazing question so when you
say um a great year do you mean
financially youall had a good windfall
year um yeah my we retired from the
military got a fantastic job um I've
moved closer to family yeah windfall
we've paid off all of our debt this year
we got the um every dollar app we've
been budgeting it's been a great year
we're finally investing 15% um for the
first time in a long time we're in our
early 40s um yeah it's just been a
really great year financially workwise
workhome balance and even just in our
our family Dynamics how old are your
kids um we have our oldest is in college
ranging down to um a one-year-old how
many six woooo and how many are foster
kids just one just one gosh dude
you're can I just like take a moment to
make this all about me for a second is
that
okay um Kelly Kelly is um producing the
show today because James is out and
Kelly produces my show and we talked
yesterday how my show has been so heavy
lately and it's been harder and harder
to hang in there and I need you to know
that talking to you for 60 seconds has
turned the light back on for me I'm
going to smile all the way home like you
give me hope that moms and dads and
neighbors and brothers and sisters are
out there changing the world and all the
Doom and Gloom is not real thank you
it's awesome yeah well it it's been a
year where we have we've seen our
children grow incredibly leave some
bounds emotionally and physically and
just their love for other people and so
we want to make sure that we invest in
into into to them that that content at
heart which they're incredibly amazing
children but also we want to we want to
Lavish them this Christmas but we don't
want to overindulge and so we're trying
to figure out where a balance is between
that um and I'll tell you what I do with
my I'll tell you what I do with my kids
okay here's how I balance it um I have a
13-year-old and a seven-year-old so your
kids are a little bit older and a little
bit younger and probably you have around
that age too so I'll tell you what my
13-year-old um I had another for a
second year in a row another number one
bestselling
book and I got the numbers yesterday on
the questions for humans they did really
well had a good year
okay my 13-year-old a I talk to him not
numbers I don't give him details but I
tell him I fact I told him this morning
on the way to school I drop them off of
school this is a year where we were
truly truly blessed truly blessed yeah
and last month I gave him the check to
hand to our church that was far in
excess of what it normally is
I also ask him to participate in tipping
the waitresses and the waiters at the
Waffle House when we go every
Tuesday and whenever somebody comes in
in a uniform I make sure he knows
they're not allowed to pay when they're
around
me so so the both end is I am
explaining we're blessed this year so
you're going to get a really cool thing
a cool thing as a dad when you have a
great year is that I get to really spoil
you and buy you gift a gift b or gift
C and this is what giving looks like in
the
wild right so I want him to see both and
and then next year if we have a tough
year um then we're going to tell him hey
we didn't have a good year this year so
I've got that conversation going with
him with the younger one she do even
know up from down like I I give her a
lot more um you know she's really GNA be
worried about she doesn't know she
doesn't know right so some of that is
just her watching us tip well care for
people well point out things um my wife
and the kids make bags for folks
homeless folks when we pull up um people
are asking we can give them things in
the winter so they they get it through
example I think the the The Meta lesson
here is kids don't listen to you they
watch
you more is caught than talk say that a
lot and so I I think what John's getting
at here is if you're not raising an
entitled kid giving them a gift is not
going to all of a sudden make an
entitled kid and so do you have a number
amount in your head of like hey we want
to spend this or is it we want to get
each kid the thing that they really want
and it's going to be $100 because kids
don't really have a concept of how much
things cost until they're older so when
I was a kid I'd get like a video camera
and a guitar and looking back I'm like
that was like $500 for that thing like
that's amazing that but it didn't it
didn't make me spoiled you know what I
mean and so what is causing you to think
that um well we this is we've never had
we've never had a year like this and so
um yeah I've my husband jokes because
I'm always a very even St person I'm
like if you have five gifts you get five
gifts and I don't care if they're
cheaper gifts or whatever but so this
year my husband said can we just pick a
dollar amount because our obviously our
older son I mean he's in college and his
sings are a lot more expensive than a
one-year-old things trying to find tell
talk to your kid about it it you're
going to teach your kid your thought
process about how you are how you give
and how you take how you um show love
and care and appreciation how you do
Christmas gifts so tell your older one
hey we're giving everybody a dollar
amount this year your stuff's way more
expensive cuz like you don't like uh you
know card games or whatever he'll get
that he'll get that the younger ones
won't they'll just look at number of
things and shiny and plastic and what
like you see what I'm saying so I would
have the conversation with the older
one okay yeah his his college was was
was a lot more expensive than everybody
else's well and he's going to it's okay
for him to be like well that kind of
sucks I want a Christmas presents and
also cuz he's a he's still a kid he's
not going to have an emotional meltdown
like a 2-year-old would when he got five
gifts and I got four you know yeah it's
like hey you got college but here's the
thing if he finds that out Christmas
morning that's kind of I don't know I
say it's not cool but oh never never it
be worth being like hey your college
cost hundred grand this year um and that
bought three books in a meal plan with
the current College prices and so your
Christmas is going to look different and
he'll go all right I get
it okay you're hey and by the way you're
not going to I the fact that you're
asking this question tells me your kids
are so far from entitled it sounds like
you haven't had this kind of security in
a long long time and you want to make
sure you you dot every eye and cross
every te and let me tell you love your
kids you're great you are great great
great well thank you so much I
appreciate you guys you too you're not
going going to mess this thing up I
promise
you thank you parent of the year right
there John that's that's a beautiful way
to end this hour it was just reminding
me uh I did this podcast here called the
fine print on Ramsey Network and I
interviewed you John for our episode on
holiday spending so I was trying to pull
it up to let the people know there's
some great encouragement there for Kim
as well it was called here it is Will
over spending Skyrocket this holiday
season due to the supply chain disaster
and in that episode we talked about how
to deal with kind of the bound issue of
like hey life's expensive inflation
hasn't cooled down the way we thought it
would and everything's still expensive
and we're all broke up to our eyeballs
it can look different this year maybe
you set that dollar amount maybe hey
we're going to get one thing for each
kid instead of seven things for each kid
this year but I like setting the
expectation and communicating the
reasons behind it I love sitting down
with my 13-year-old and saying this is a
year we've been blessed which means
we're going to give like
crazy and you're going to get something
pretty cool and I'm taking you on a trip
so that's going to be factored into this
thing too and I want you to know that
when it comes to Christmas morning you
that trip isn't wrapped in a present and
it's going to feel weird and you're not
broken so I'm explaining to him as this
thing goes and he's going to go okay
okay all right so yeah he'll be
disappointed that there's not 700
presents under the tree but he's
learning that's not how my old man shows
appreciation and also he talked to me
about this I knew this was coming and so
it's it's both and yeah well usually the
disappointment is on the other side of a
lack of setting expectations and
communicating so that's the key but
beautiful way to end the show thank you
so much Kim that puts this hour of the
Ramsey Show in the books my thanks to Dr
John deloney Kelly our producer for
today's show crushing it all the folks
in there keeping the show float in
America thing America's favorite Kelly
holding it down we'll be back before you
know it in the meantime spend wisely
save intentionally and give
generously
[Music]
la